Добрий день Мене звати Ксенія польська я
зараз знаходжуся у страсбурзі у Франції
у приміщенні Європейського парламенту де
сьогодні відбулася церемонія
нагородження премією імені Сахарова
цього року її отримали українці
сьогодні на церемонії представникам
українського народу аплодували стоячи
кілька хвилин
президента Європейського парламенту
Роберта мецола пообіцяла і надалі
підтримувати Україну не тільки
символічно але й подальшими діями
український народ проти стоїть
загарбницькій війні Росії зазнає
колосальних втрат у вигляді втрачених
життів та зруйнованих міст і сіл кажуть
у європарламенті
крім того номінація відзначає президента
України Володимира Зеленського за його
Мужність витримку та відданість своєму
народові
ініціатори цієї резолюції розповіли що
консерватори в європарламенті хотіли
бачити лауреатом тільки президента
Зеленського мовляв щоб Таким чином
виступити проти Путіна але більшість
парламентарів вирішила що йдеться не про
Путіна і що Зеленський герой Але разом з
ним героєм є і всі українці
Щоб отримати цю премію від імені всіх
українців у Страсбург приїхали голова
окупованого Мелітополя Іван Федоров
Ярослав Божко з громадського руху опору
жовта стрічка
парами дикіня Тайра Юлія паєвська та
правозахисниця Олександра Матвійчук Мені
дуже пощастило і я в кулуарах
Європейського парламенту побачила
Олександру Матвійчук Ось вона з нами
і зараз я їх запитаю чому це так важливо
сьогодні що українці отримують отримують
цю премію досить символічно що вперше за
всю історію премії її вручають народу і
в назві премії звучить що вона
вручається сміливим людям в Україні і
направду це дуже
заслужена відзнака тому що коли є
міжнародні організації евакуювали після
масштабно вторгнення свій став то люди
лишилися на місцях і робили надзвичайну
роботу звичайні люди які робили
надзвичайні речі от вони зараз ми всі
відзначені І це
ще раз підкреслюю що йде війна не просто
між двома країнами що йде війна між
двома системами авторитаризмом і
демократією і міжнародна спільнота на
нашій стороні
Я відчувала таку суміш відчуттів треба
ще було бути в самому залі щоб передати
цю атмосферу щоб її
відчути і Найперше я відчувала гордість
бути частиною українського народу якого
нагороджують
по-друге я відчувала величезну
відповідальність тому що це можливості
які ми використаємо для того щоб
перестали гинути люди на фронті
перестали ги ці люди в окупації
перестали гинути люди в тилу Ну і також
мені складно назвати це відчуття але я
зрозуміла що мало бути разом з нами ще
дуже багато людей навіть тих яких я
знала особисто але вони не зможуть бути
бо вони віддали своє життя вони віддали
своє життя за наш демократичний вибір і
за свободу
фонд премії 50 тисяч євро але її
справжні значення полягає в тому що це
найвища нагорода Європейського
парламенту таким чином він демонструє
свої найголовніші цінності та пріоритети
насправді Це історична подія тому що
багато видатних людей отримували цю
премію від Нельсона мандели до Олега
Сенцова
день у Європейському парламенті
завершився у страсбурзі вже вечір і я
хочу попрощатися з вами до наступних
зустрічей як Ксенія польська зі
страсбурга для Deutsche Welle